[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM SNEATH: Thank you so much.
Welcome to Flutter Live.
Thank you all for coming.
This is a global event.
We have hundreds of thousands
of people watching this
all over the world,
whether via livestream
or at the over 150 viewing
parties around the world.
Whether you're watching us
over a morning cup of coffee
in Seattle, or whether you're
attending a meeting after work
in Berlin or joining a pajama
party in Bangkok, welcome.
I want to start by paying
credit to the many software
engineers who contributed
to this project
and without whom we
wouldn't all be here today.
With Flutter, we assembled
the best engineering talent
from across the
industry, all of whom
shared a dream of reinventing
how user interfaces are built.
Our team includes leaders with
pedigrees from web, desktop,
and mobile UI toolkits.
It includes the former
editor of the HTML standard,
leading developers who have
worked on WebKit and Blink,
and architects who created
the first version of V8,
the JavaScript engine
that powers Chrome.
And then beyond our
own team, we also
have hundreds of contributors
from the community
who have identified issues,
contributed to patches,
and even introduced
new features.
And all of that has brought
us to this moment today.
This isn't just our product,
but it's your product,
and we're so proud to be
part of the journey with you.
So let's talk about Flutter.
Our vision for Flutter is
something that many of us
have been dreaming
of for years--
a powerful, general
purpose, open UI toolkit
for building stunning
experiences on any device--
embedded, mobile,
desktop, or beyond.
While we're still in the
early stages of this journey,
we're already depending
on Flutter ourselves
at Google to power many
different apps and services.
We know from direct
experience that it's
ready for beautiful
production apps,
and now we're delighted
to share it with you also.
Our immediate focus
is the mobile phone.
Developers today are
forced to compromise
between either building
the same app multiple times
on multiple operating
systems or accepting a lowest
common denominator solution
that trades native speed
and accuracy for portability.
With Flutter, the days of
compromise are finally over.
There are four
characteristics of Flutter
that we think make it a
unique platform for you
to build native mobile
application experiences.
Firstly, Flutter enables
you to build beautiful apps.
As you'll hear later, Flutter
provides a rich palette
of tools that give you control
over every pixel on the screen.
Designers will never again have
to compromise on their vision.
Flutter includes a
full set of widgets
that deliver pixel-perfect
experiences on both iOS
and Android.
And it enables the ultimate
realization of material design.
So whether you're building
a highly tailored, branded
experience or a native
iPhone or Android app,
you should find that
Flutter provides
everything you need to build
a beautiful, award-winning
interface.
Secondly, Flutter is fast.
I'ts powered by the blazing
speed Skia 2D graphics engine
which enables
hardware-accelerated graphics.
From the start, we
architected Flutter
to be able to support
glitch-free, jank-free graphics
at the native speed
of your display.
Flutter code is compiled.
It's not interpreted.
It doesn't go through
a virtual machine.
When your application
is finished,
it's compiled to
native machine code.
Thirdly, Flutter is productive.
Flutter introduces a
revolutionary new capability
for developers and designers
to iterate on their apps
in real time, and we call
this stateful hot reload.
And it enables you to
change the code of your app
and see the changes in
real time without having
to restart the app or get
back to the screen you are on.
And we think stateful
hot reload transforms
the way you build an app.
And developers who use it-- some
of you may be here in the room
today--
say it makes them up to
three times more productive.
And lastly, Flutter is open.
Flutter itself is open source--
open for contributions,
open for extensibility.
Every line of code
is available for you
to read, fork, extend, amend.
You don't have to buy a
developer tool to use Flutter
or to use its tools.
Everything is licensed freely
under a BSD-style license.
And of course, that openness
extends to the community.
There are already thousands
of Flutter plug-ins out there.
And of course anything that
the underlying operating system
exposes is available to
Flutter, whether it's
written in Kotlin or
Java on Android or Swift
or Objective C on iOS.
So put all this together,
combine it with best in class
tooling for Visual Studio Code
or Android Studio, IntelliJ,
or the programming
editor of your choice,
and you have Flutter--
a framework for building
beautiful native experiences
for iOS or Android from
a single code base.
So what does this mean for you?
Well, as a business, you no
longer need to fund two teams.
You can put all your
resources towards crafting
one beautiful native experience
that's available everywhere
you need to be.
But today, we're not just
here to talk about Flutter.
We want to show you some
examples of Flutter in action.
And to do that,
here's Filip Hracek.
Over to you, Filip.
[APPLAUSE]
FILIP HRACEK: Thank you.
Thank you.
So Tim told you about the
four tenets of Flutter--
beautiful, fast,
productive, and open.
And it was OK.
It was a little bit theoretical.
But fortunately, I'm here now.
And I'm going to
show you how that
translates to practical stuff.
So we built an app
for this event.
It's called The
History of Everything.
And I'm going to give you
a little tour of the app,
and I'm going to show you how
different things about Flutter
made things possible
or at least easier.
So I'll start with the basics.
The app starts immediately.
This is because Flutter compiles
ahead of time to arm code.
So there's no Jit to warm up.
There are no scripts to parse.
It just starts executing-- fast.
Second, this is an Android
device, and this is an iPhone.
And as you can see,
the basic interaction
is completely natural.
If you go to a different
screen, everything
works as you would expect.
So these are the basics.
And this is how
Flutter makes you
productive by letting you
focus on the custom stuff
while doing the basics itself.
We're going to get rid
of one of the phones
just because it's
distracting to have two.
And I'm just going
to focus on this one.
So let's take this
a little further.
It's nice to have scrolling, but
how can we turn this up to 11?
So in this view, we have this
very interactive, very animated
timeline where you can go from--
all the way from
Big Bang to today.
And if you see that red dot,
that's all of human history.
We'll get back to that.
But what I'm going to
show you now is actually--
so the scroll behavior is
still completely natural
to the platform, but
we added this really--
I think it's fun
bouncy effect, just
to make it more interesting
to interact with the app.
And this is actually a testament
to the openness of Flutter,
because we were able
to use Flutter physics,
scroll physics, and add
a custom layer on top.
So Flutter is not just
open as in open source,
as you can read the
code, of course.
But also, it gives
you, as a developer,
access to all these classes and
functionality that you can then
build on top of.
But let's take this
a little further.
So it's nice to
scroll, but let's zoom.
So I'm going to zoom right past
dinosaurs, because it turns out
nobody likes dinosaurs.
Humans.
This is the red dot
that we saw earlier.
And now, as you can see, at any
moment, at any scroll position,
at any zoom level, we show
what makes the most sense.
And that is possible, again,
because Flutter is fast.
We can actually recompute
what you show on every frame.
And this is basically a
requirement for any very custom
UI where you want to be able
to rebuild things and be
interactive, 60
frames per second.
OK.
Well, let's take this
a little bit further.
So you might be thinking,
oh, these are cool.
I like these little animations.
And you might also be thinking
that these are actually
pre-computed, a GIF
or maybe a video.
But these are actually
vector animations
that we're building on
every frame with Flutter.
So for example, this one, I can
sway the tree above of Newton.
And I like how the apple
still falls on Newton's head.
It's because life is hard.
And this is possible because,
again, Flutter is fast,
but also, because Flutter,
at its deepest level,
uses Skia engine.
Skia is hardware accelerated.
It paints directly to
your graphics card,
and you own all the pixels.
So whatever beautiful design
your designer designs, whatever
artwork your art person
does, you can do it.
And you can do it, again,
for 60 frames per second.
And that's really cool.
Now you might be thinking,
this is all cool,
but you're showing Pixel 3.
That's a very modern phone.
How about older phones?
And I'm glad you asked.
Because by chance, I have
other phones with me today.
So this is an Android
phone from 2014, Samsung.
And it's running, I
think, Android Kit Kat.
And as you can see,
it works just fine.
And here, if I can
make it go away--
and here we have an iPhone
from 2013, so five years ago.
And again, it runs just fine.
So it's not just
the modern phones.
If we go to the computer
screen, what magic is this?
I'm not going to
do any live coding,
but I just wanted you to see
that it's just Flutter code.
The app itself is all Flutter.
There is no magic behind it.
It's all the Flutter that you
all probably-- or at least many
of you know and love.
So it just compiles to APK
for Android and IPA for iOS,
and then it gets
published to the stores.
This is actually published
maybe two hours ago.
This is the app store, and
this is the Play Store.
If we get back to the phone--
so yeah, we were able--
in maybe something like
6,000 lines of code,
were able to build a very
custom app in three months
with three people who were
busy doing other stuff as well.
So that's the productive part.
But there are things
that you won't
find in the released
version of the app.
Why?
Because I believe that just
because you can do something
with Flutter doesn't
mean you should.
For example, can you add
150 little animated hearts
to the timeline?
Let's scroll with it and
get bigger and smaller
and all that.
Sure.
Should you do that?
No.
Maybe yes, but no.
Second that we didn't
add to the production app
is the last event
in the timeline.
And that is obviously
Flutter Live,
because the history
of everything
ends with Flutter Live.
No, think about it.
Everything that ever happened
since the history of time
has led us to this moment.
It's true.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
A little bit of philosophy.
Anyway, what I
wanted to show here
is that Flutter is all widgets.
It's open, and it's composable.
So if we want to have a video
playing in our very custom
timeline, and being included
by all these things,
we can, because it's
just another way to--
it's Flutter, so sure.
The last thing I want to
show you is basically this.
But can we take it
a little further?
So that's the blue
dot just above here,
and that is actually a
very substantial event
in the history of everything.
This is me trying to find
this venue earlier today.
I got lost in London,
and I was very sad.
But I had a device with me
connected to the internet.
And there's this
service by Google
that you use if you have a
phone with you and you're lost.
And as you can see in
this little animation--
wait, what is this?
Can you see that?
Let me zoom in.
Oh, is this an actual
Google map running
inside my Flutter application
while it's being swayed around?
Sure.
[APPLAUSE]
Because this is Flutter,
so it's another widget.
OK.
So to summarize, we've
seen an application
that I think is beautiful,
that was built in three months
by three people, that is fast
on a wide range of devices,
and that, because of
the openness of Flutter,
can do cool things like this.
Thank you for attention.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: Thanks, Filip.
What do you think?
[APPLAUSE]
So to me, that's a great
example of Flutter.
It's a beautiful experience
that does things that even
a traditional native platform
solution might struggle to do.
So you've seen a little
of what Flutter can do.
And today, it gives
me great pleasure
to announce the general
availability of Flutter 1.0.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So today's release
marks a key milestone
for the product where
we declare it's not
just ready for early adopters.
It's ready for everyone.
We released the
first beta of Flutter
back at Mobile World Congress
in February of this year.
And looking back over
the last nine months,
it's been really quite
humbling from our point of view
to see how people have adopted
and responded to Flutter.
Since February, well over a
quarter of a million developers
have used Flutter.
Companies large and
small, including the likes
of Alibaba, Groupon,
Tencent, Capital
One, Philips Hue,
and of course Google,
are developing with Flutter.
And even in this
pre-release stage
up till now, we've seen
over 3,000 apps published
on the Play Store alone reaching
hundreds of millions of users.
To show you some of the
momentum that already exists
for Flutter, we
thought it would be fun
to put together a quick video
that shows the great work
that many of you have
done with Flutter so far.
[MUSIC PLAYING]